my mission was to get close to the
chimpanzees to live among them
to be accepted when I was 10 and I said
I'm going to grow up go to Africa live
with wild animals and write books about
them everybody laughed I wanted to do
things which men did or women they would
Jane grew up in a time when women did
not do the type of work she did and she
was going to be deterred everything was
so different I didn't have any
responsibilities except to learn about
the chimpanzees thanks to Brett Morgan
and the way that he treated this footage
it took me right back we had a hundred
fifty hours of disparate shots so that
we heart an army of people to come in
and I gave him categories like mating or
eating or sleeping and so we could at
least see everything grouped in
successes we can get a sense what we
have and it was very emotional for me to
see my life unrolling there's more about
my personal life than that there has
been in the other documentaries I
decided that I needed to have a point of
view and I was going to express that
point of view through music to achieve
that I enlisted the support and aid of
Philip Glass and when Philip delivered
his first cue I had tears going down my
eyes I think he said I think I might
have fallen in love with you and it's
come together to be rather an
extraordinary film so what I hope is
it's going to bring back into people's
minds a renewed determination to do that
it to save what's left of this planet
[Music]
[Music]